our Disney wish has a new propulsion
system this is definitely a used an
azipod which is an electric motor driven
propeller under the water really allows
for some amazing performance
[Music]
we've made the step from going from a
conventional shaft line propeller and
rotor to potted propulsion which means
it's a propulsion motor that hangs
underneath the ship and it can turn 360
degrees not only are they very very
maneuverable they're also very
hydrodynamically efficient if you want
to stop the ship
from going forward you start closing him
this would be stopped engine so stop
engines in classic propulsa 0 RPMs is
because it puts pointing towards each
other and then if you want to go a stir
you start turning them backwards our
Disney wish has a new propulsion system
there is no shaft line that needs to go
into the ship it gives the naval
architect the opportunity to design the
half shape of the hull underwater almost
freely so they can optimize the flow
into the propeller in the best possible
way so these are Big right the
propellers are more than six meters now
this is two meters so you can just think
six meters in diameter they're huge
we're in the ASI powder room and this is
the port azipod and this is what's
making us go forward the propulsion
system is is the big buzz but the other
big new feature for us is the LNG system
LNG of course is liquid natural gas it
has less emissions
um it's cleaner burning and so all
around a better fuel to use so we're
pleased to be part of that Revolution
we're going to take that LNG on board
it's coming on at -164 degrees C so
we're dealing with cryogenic technology
at the moment we have two large tanks
they're about the size of 10 school
buses so we have two tanks that are 10
school buses each that liquid comes on
so we then transform it into gas to put
into the engines that has an expansion
ratio from liquid into gas to 600 times
so if you think of 10 score buses then
expanding 600 times that's how much gas
we have in each tank
today is the day where we determine the
maximum speed we start the first
measurement
[Music]
for us it's very important to see that
she reaches the right speed that she
Maneuvers properly
[Music]
you over exceeded our expectations the
speed tests the maneuvering trials
she'll use less energy She Is So Silent
she'll be sailing more easily we made
sure that she's an awesome ship and that
is everything for us
[Music]
thank you